we are joined here in the studio by John
worth an EU citizen with a UK passport
and and also a blogger who writes quite
extensively on the EU and the UK welcome
back to the program could you mean we
have to talk about what has just been
happening now in the past 24 hours I
mean we essentially have some of her
most senior cabinet members gone we have
this brexit secretary that basically no
one's ever heard of she seems to be
recycling people amber Rudd also back
what does this say about the state of
British politics right now essentially
Teresa Mays position becomes more and
more perilous with every passing day
with every passing week but nevertheless
no one dares get rid of her and so
ultimately she's got nowhere else to go
other than to try people she's tried
before in the case of Rudd or to take
over in people like Barkley and so her
position however no one is quite ready
to just tip her over the edge to get rid
of her altogether because none of them
want the job either because try to
negotiate breaks it is that hard and so
therefore that's the thing if you keep
her then she has to deliver the bad news
to the British population and then all
of the other conservatives are lining up
to take over the moment the breaks it
actually happens nobody wants to hold
the hot potato that is Berg said you
know the big question now is really will
she survive as Prime Minister and will
her brexit plan get through and I just
like to do a quick reset here remind our
viewers actually how all of this came
about and then get your reaction
thereafter so let's have a listen as we
leave the European Union we will forge a
forge a bold new positive role for
ourselves in the world brexit knees
brexit brexit means brexit and we're
going to make a success of it I'm very
clear bricks it does mean breakfast it's
the issue that's defined her Premiership
from day one through the snap general
election she called last year a lost
majority it was after a crunch July
summit at her country estate that
Theresa May began losing ministers over
her brexit plan for exit secretary David
Davis was first to go followed by
foreign secretary Boris Johnson for
months on it's all come to a head again
in her car
it's after hours of closed-door talks
the collective decision of cabinet was
that the government should agree the
draft withdrawal agreement and the
outlying political declaration
the morning after her second breaks at
secretary Dominic Raab resigned saying
he could not support the deal despite
this the Prime Minister has a marriage
more determined than ever do you want a
microphone this is a deal which does
deliver that which is in the national
interest and am I going to see this
through yes but others remain
unconvinced surely now even you have to
admit this is not strong and stable you
know MPs have been debating the best way
to deliver brexit ever since the
referendum took place in 2016 and
there's been much criticism throughout
that time of the government's approach
people have been ready to point out what
they don't like but one simple fact
remains and that is that nobody has
produced any alternative proposal which
both delivers on the referendum and also
ensures that there's no hard border
between Northern Ireland and Ireland
thank you as members of her own party
continue to seek a vote of no confidence
in Prime Minister me many people are
asking if her Premiership can survive
Matan ultimately I mean we just heard
her stated there there is no alternative
to her and her plan she's correct right
I mean she's gonna survive this isn't
she she is going to survive I think
until the middle of December I think we
can say that with some certainty that's
when the House of Commons will vote on
her brexit plans so she can manage to
just about hold her government together
but when that face is the hard reality
of the votes in Parliament that's when
it's going to get much much tougher does
she have the numbers of parliamentarians
to agree her deal and to ultimately then
get on with getting breaks it done by
March of 2019 so her government monic
just about back her and she might hold
that together the next few weeks but
then when it comes to the votes in in
the House of Commons there the numbers
look very very bad for Theresa May so I
would give her a few more weeks but
probably not more than a month and it's
so interesting because you
here this extreme skepticism coming out
of the UK just generally speaking um but
I just like to get a quick assessment of
you know the way things that stand here
in the EU we actually had the
opportunity one of my colleagues Fabien
founder mark to speak with one of the
European People's Party members in the
European Parliament that was Elmar Brok
and I just like to play what he said
here and they get your reaction to it
thereafter I can see you already
interesting Terry but here we go
mr. poke the brexit deal had been on the
table barely a day before it was hugely
criticised in London and ministers
resigned what do you think of the
proposed deal I think this is a very
good deal that is not everything as we
as Europeans liked it but we have now an
insurance backstop for our border that
there is no control as all no hard
border that would help but it could have
been an easier way but the Brits did not
want it that easier way and now we have
on that basis the possibility after
ratification of this restore agreement
to negative future relationship with a
far-reaching for a free trade agreement
for example so that this Customs Union
question which is software used as
backstop will not take me coming to
practice any time because we have a
prominent future good relationship in
trade matters do you still think Teresa
may can get the deal through the House
of Commons and couldn't you or could
Germany help somehow the new sessions
are concluded and this is your offer
wishes in a table where both governments
the Commission and the British
government have agreed to and now we
have to ratify the European Parliament
in a council they have to do it at home
and therefore wherever one has to look
whether he finds him Authority for that
what he is negotiated
if the deal fails should the EU and the
UK really face the consequences of a
heart brexit or should the UK then hold
another referendum this is up to the UK
to hold a second referendum the time is
shows they have to do it until the end
of February because 29th of March the
out and therefore I would welcome if
they do a second referendum because I
would like to have Britain in but I'm
not sure that under this political
circumstances where no real political
party and no political leader takes the
lead in such a question it can be
achieved thank you very much mr. Bach
okay so John you told us before we heard
that interview that you don't think it's
gonna get through the British Parliament
I mean but we just heard brock basically
say he thinks it's gonna pass through
the european union also like a brace he
makes it sound so easy but i think the
EU side is easier because essentially
the european union side has got what it
wanted in this negotiation it's the
british side that's had to swallow some
some bitter pills in this negotiation so
far so i don't see a problem on the
european union side or in the european
parliament if the system you know you
think it's gonna meet the approval of
all EU member states you need only a
majority of the European Union member
states to back it and I don't think that
that's a problem because essentially
they've basically been working very
closely with the eves chief negotiator
until now if this is to fail this is not
gonna fail now it's not gonna fail on
the EU side it will fail on the UK
second do you think that bergsøe is
going to happen by the deadline and I
think there's going to be a delay and
there I disagree for Elmar Brok said
because he said the British would have
to hold a referendum by February I don't
think that that's possible in the UK to
organise it so quickly and so therefore
if it fails in Parliament which I think
will happen in December what happens
then
Britain crashes out without a deal which
no one wants the British don't want the
EU doesn't want and so you go down the
rich having another referendum but you
can't do that by February as Elmar Brok
was saying you need more time and so
Theresa May or the British government
then in December in January will have to
go back to Brussels and say we need more
time so as we can hold a referendum and
so Brussels needs to prepare itself that
brexit is not going to happen on time
John worth brexit experts and bloggers
we thank you so much for joining us this
evening to share that view we appreciate
it